it's third and we're live
hello and welcome to the weekly poll as
usual I'm Benny the comic story and that
is Sal from comic pop that is Rob from
Marble explain because I didn't change
it but it's actually comics explained
you all know that it is Faust form it's
super effective no it has nothing to do
with Pokemon he just likes the
terminology and this is the old money be
all incredible the all-encompassing
the only one of us who's I think over a
half a million over here eros from
various comics you know like all right
guys today as usual we're gonna be going
over our topics and we're gonna be
discussing things and it's gonna be fun
and you guys are all going to enjoy it
and Rob is going to vape and sell is
going to interrupt everybody and I'm
gonna pretend I'm paying attention when
I'm playing a through D s game it's
gonna be great it's gonna be what city
optics are going to be convergence we're
gonna discuss the eight or nine releases
from last week and we're also going to
be discussing be daredevil TV show but
we've already agreed previously to this
that we are going to be holding off on
any daredevil spoilers right we agreed
to episodes maybe
yeah like stuff unless the chat is
overwhelmingly like don't like what yeah
the first two episodes are open game as
far as we're concerned right now
everything beyond that cuz I haven't
even gotten past episode six yet so oh
god yeah man well not all of us do a 13
hour livestream in which we just eat
food on camera no spoilers it only gets
better it's funny just jumping into
daredevil I not I don't want to
circumvent convergence or whatever that
would be
but like I'm actually kind of
disappointed that they're doing Iron
Fist and Jessica Jones and Luke Cage now
because all I want is a season two of
daredevil like the more I'm watching
daredevil the more I'm like we're
getting to the end there's only 13
episodes I really don't care about Luke
Cage let's get more dude okay you know
I'll agree with you I don't care what
Luke Cage but I do want to see jessica
jones in the purple man and i do want to
see iron fist iron fist on screen
they're gonna be great yes I don't know
about that but yes
I think it's gonna it's dude absolutely
here's what its gonna feel like watching
Danny Rand on Netflix is gonna feel like
a throwback to the 1970s kung fu movies
I don't know if I can handle 13 episodes
of Danny Rand here's the kicker like
like it's dark as daredevil is right now
you know with you guys left at issues
number I guess I kept a--so is number
six and seven and so on like if that
shows as dark as it is imagine what
Jessica Jones is going to look like if
but with more ray penis in it because
it's Netflix and they can get away with
that yeah I'm actually amazed with how
much they're how much envelope-pushing
is happening but then how much like how
careful they are about it so that if ABC
let's say decides like oh crap this is
doing really well you know we're just
gonna launch it on ABC like we're you
know next year 22 2016 we've got like a
really slow you know week or castle
finally gets canceled we'll just throw
it on there and then we'll just double
really objectionable curse words because
they anytime they curse it's like uh so
you're you're like okay they can they
can fudge that yeah what what do you
think Aris about the whole daredevil
this show is coming ups it was I guess
we're gonna open with that I love it so
far I was really shocked because this is
as most people know and I'm sure all you
know it's connected to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe yeah so for me I've
been thanks to the from the beginning
that with Luke Cage the defenders short
or miniseries coming after this Jessica
Jones of well that's a fine fist this is
a way for them to get more characters
out so to put into the civil war movies
during you know a lot of superheroes and
so that's my theory so they can just
throw them in there but I was really
shocked just because how dark it was
liking a person to like Thor Captain
America iron in all the movies like it
is like complete opposite which I love
but I was just like how is this gonna
work with like the fun kind of poppy
vibe of you know the Avengers and stuff
when Whedon or the Russo brothers get
ahold of it cuz they're gonna I don't
know if I have to turn like tone it down
a little bit right or kind of you know I
don't know that much but I love this
show so far I think I love how they're
going the Frank Miller out yeah kind of
like I'm not there yet but you with I
think there's an episode titled stick I
haven't watched it yet it's almost you
mean they get really in
so that and stuff so I just really it's
a keeps shock because a lot of moments
like a Walking Dead moments where you're
like oh my god I can't believe you did
that like you know took this guy's
eyeball out or whatnot it's like that's
crazy
no I agree at the moment that we I'm
sorry but there's one second just to me
I'm not I didn't end it technically
interrupt files he didn't talk you well
I was gonna say I agree with yours
because the moment without going to
explain it what happened that he arm
gets broken and like you see the bone
exposed and everything I'm like how is
this going to work with Captain America
and Thor because like you said they're
all poppy and fun and like cat like I
just these are these images of like you
know Captain America daredevil meeting
and daredevil goes to one of the thugs
and he beats him up but he breaks his
arm and it's got this caps just like oh
my god like why did you do that I've
been up 25 guys in no one's injured yeah
what I hit them with my with my shield
they just went like Kabong crack or they
especially I'm not gonna say what it was
but those are something with a rib
that's all I'm gonna say what they do
and I'm like are you kidding me I mean I
think it's it should probably work but
it'll be a lot like when a character
from a dark comic appears in a light
comic just because like if you pay
attention to what mumbles done at the
moment even compare Captain America
Winter Soldier to the Avengers maybe two
very different turn a letís but same
character and it worked and they even
just changed the costume to make it work
and change the color palette so I think
just subtle things like that it will
probably work but with a big change like
daredevil into like an Avengers maybe it
will probably be a bit like I'm slightly
uncomfortable here comes an Avenger but
I could definitely see him being the
spider-man character in Civil War like
where he does the identity reveal I see
but they've already pretty much said now
that we got spider-man like yeah but
like you can't you can't unmask
spider-man in your movie if you're gonna
make him in high school you can't put
the genie back in the bottle with you in
your more cinematic universe and all
those do is see for one more day a brand
new day
so do you think they might roll with us
spider-man and daredevil in Civil War
where spider-man's the one that gets
arrested and there that was the one that
does the identity reveal that could be I
I definitely think that I was gonna do
the identity reveal because we've had
almost what 20 years of daredevil being
out it it's already pretty much an
established character like a trait for
him to be identically known as daredevil
so I think that that's like a natural
thing for them to do they could just be
like oh no we marvel cinematic did where
we took this thing you know and we just
did our own version of it
but I don't know about spider-man he
definitely is gonna be in it but III I
think that he'll probably be more like a
like a like a like a MacGuffin like
spider-man got captured and I know he's
just a kid we have to go break him out
like that kind of thing what kind of
makes sense I could I could see that I
see here's if they do this because I
want to say just really apply man you
and your hair just just no no because I
want as they were quick cuz think about
this real quick just with what you're
saying so about daredevil being in the
reveal what that would do for Netflix
daredevil season 2 that whole season
could be about him dealing with it would
just be the Bendis run yes basically
what they're like that's what everyone
wants like next season one is clearly
just Frank Miller's daredevil season two
could be Bendis is daredevil and season
three could be Marc Wade's daredevil
okay so now that the hair is done
talking Rob just once anyway so alright
so so here's here's a question here's
something really cool like as far as I
understand it Captain America 3 Civil
War that's supposed to start Civil War
like it's not supposed to be the entire
Civil War film encompass or the entire
still working to be that encompassed in
one film like as I understand it
supposed to started like it that's
because I mean like that would make the
most sense to me now if they did that if
they said okay Captain America 3 and
that starts a civil war then that gives
you the entire second season of dare
right and that gives you the entire
second season of Jessica Jones and not
really just to get jobs because she'll
just take off and go to Canada and
they'll be it so what you're saying is
they're gonna stick to being very true
to civil Civil War by having a whole
bunch of totally irrelevant spin-offs to
the story work but no no I mean at that
point it's just it's just fanfare it's
just kind of what I would be hoping for
um
assuming that they do keep it confined
to one movie I think that was I think
that idea makes the most sense because
using daredevil an established character
is saying he keeps his identity hidden
and I guess maybe switching his role
with with spider-man would would be
interesting but I think one of the big
reasons why there was the big push for
spider-man in civil war was so that
people could turn around and we could
have the big spider-man moment where he
reveals his identity to the world like
that was the pivotal spider-man that's
why fine was important in civil war
because he revealed his identity and
then gave credence to iron man's entire
stance on registration something that
Miller wanted to do in the first place
and so you can have that moment with
daredevil I think people just a so I
think that people who don't know know
the comics or who or have a very cursory
knowledge of them are gonna be like
spider-man is directly associate with
Civil War I don't remember why but I
know that like spider-man and civil war
are synonymous with each other so he
needs to be in it I'm just saying that
they like I want the relationship with
Tony and Peter Parker because I also
want to see the iron spider suit like
he's in that movie and we don't see the
iron spider suit I am going to be pissed
I don't we love it like we could not
really switching gears but getting into
it with like the ant-man trailer which
finally a trailer that actually matches
the tone of what ant-man supposed to be
with a man trailer for two it looks
great and you get to see yellowjacket
for the first time yeah that guy gets
suit reminded me of the irons later the
first thing I thought I think that's not
the best moment that trailer is that is
the Thomas the Tank Engine Thomas you're
um you're in
see I don't I don't watch trailers but
I'm going to see The Avengers next week
and I'm terrified I'm gonna be forced to
watch the trailer cuz I can't walk out
listen to mine I'm just gonna be like
familiar Faust is going to see the
premiere night mode premiere it's just a
screening a screening of before all of
us means you're gonna get the Star Wars
trailer huh I know so much about Star
Wars I mean I've seen all of them many
times I've never seen anything to do
with stole never read a Star Wars comic
and never played this game but I know
exactly what happens because it
everywhere it's in my blood so daredevil
you are you are in a singular way my
friend you could it's like a unicorn
like someone who hasn't seen Star Wars
who's also into this culture no one else
really all right I didn't realize that
the trailer for episode 7 was coming out
with age of Ultron but no oh chat will
probably dispute me but we'll see yeah
well now that makes me more excited
because like half the fun is going to
see that the trailers which is like nine
times out of ten they're usually crappy
except for like one or two yeah but if
going into the trailers people are alike
we get to see this trailer for Star Wars
Episode seven I'm like yes old Mark
Hamill I'm so excited why don't ya now
here's here's okay so many we're getting
back to to the terrace so with what
you've seen of kingpin so far like
what's your take on kingpins character
because I love him it's especially like
when they first introduced him for the
first few well the first few episodes
after they introduced I'm like I'm on
Episode six so I haven't I don't you
know I haven't seen I still have half
the season
go well from what I've seen it's it's
crazy to see like the tone I guess the
actors going with where it's very much
like like a nuts sort of zappy but like
a kind of like I don't try to put my
fingers on the word in order
misunderstood he's very soft-spoken he's
not like he's not like this straight
like in-your-face tough guy you know
they're taking like they're very like
backseat approach where he'll beat the
crap out of you but it's very different
from like you know people you see stuff
in like the Spiderman animated series
I'm sure everyone's seen that that's the
affinity of pink kingpin for a lot of
you exactly that's what so I like it I
mean uh I kind of was expecting
something different but uh I'm enjoying
it so far I really I think it fits in
with this world they're creating where
it's very dark it's more realistic to me
it's that's why I like this almost seems
like the the Dark Knight of daredevil in
a sense very much like kingpin begins
that's right yeah yeah taking the whole
concept of Batman basically but you've
heard a lot of people say oh yes
Marvel's family this does feel like like
Batman Begins like that kind of like
Scott Snyder even tweeted out that he
wishes that you know the Batman and a
Nolan film spot like daredevil oh yeah
because in the Nolan films Batman just
like oh you're just like blocking and
like stands there until everyone gets
exhausted
my suit will protect me yeah the people
who are making Gotham must be just like
crapping themselves right because I'm
sure it's a fraction of the cost of
making Gotham to make terrible and you
actually get the freaking character in
your show and he's cool anyway like you
could just like wouldn't well we don't
have to stop with wasted potential of
Gotham but like just you know it must be
frustrating for them cuz this pretty
much is just a Batman show but like you
know but Marvel but you know what I
think it is when it comes to Batman
Gotham arrow even the daredevil DC is
scared to do the Batman show because I
have a feeling they're like if it bombs
that's it we never get a Batman show
again my guy but that's like come on
you're gonna get bet you can you can
reboot Batman six more times in the next
three years and everyone will go Batman
and Robin torched the franchise freakin
saw Batman and Robin and everybody and
like it's just like how they say every
Transformers movie kills the franchise
but it's the highest-grossing film of
that year right burn the franchise down
everyone saw it so they can all say it
sucked
the final Transformers movie had like a
14 percent on Rotten Tomatoes and I made
like 750 exam dollars or something
stupid movies really Marky Mark yeah in
there yeah me sing but but no like like
here is here's here's to me like I love
the kingpin in in the show so far and
here's exactly why here's why I love the
kingpin the kingpin in the show so far
reminds me of rise of kingpin they came
out in 2003 or something like that and
that was like kingpins rise to power
that was it was the it was like that
comic was basically like we're gonna
take the Godfather and we're gonna
replace Michael Corleone with and then
we're gonna publish it it's like a six
or seven issue limited series and it's
gonna be really good and it was it was
it was an extremely good series but it's
like it chronicled his rise to power
which I really really enjoyed and that
that depiction of Wilson Fisk is what
reminds me of the Wilson Fisk and in the
internet flick series not only that like
he's an amalgamation or different kinds
of Wilson Fisk I mean you saw Vince with
spider-man in the animated series and
you see elements of Frank Miller's there
or Frank Miller's Wilson Fisk kingpin
when he brought him over from Amazing
Spiderman like you see all these
different elements of kingpin thrown
into the character and that I think is
really what makes him such a great
version is because a lot of people look
at him and five different people will
see his character and they'll all see
something different depending on what
stories they read and which version that
came from they thought was the best
which I thought was pretty solid that
was bringing I want to ask everybody
about this eras no one's you to lead off
on this discussion but the fight
sequences for daredevil compared to like
the movies and stuff like that because
for me the moment that made that sold me
on the show the
first episode there okay but it was the
fight sequence at the end of episode 2
the almost no cutaway secrets where it's
in the hallway and you just see him
beating on like all these different guys
and they don't cut away except for when
they pan around it which may have been a
cut away or whatever but it's still a
lot of long held sequences and in
general I personally enjoyed the
fighting sequences because of that
because it wasn't just a bunch of quick
cuts with Captain America thrown upon
shaky-cam back has america thrown up on
shaky cam it was we're gonna steady this
cam and you're gonna see daredevil fight
yeah what do you guys think about that
well I I love it like I feel like the
fight sequence or krahgg choreography in
this is like similar to the raid I don't
know if any of you've seen those movies
where yeah just where's the very lot
like you said very long shots with just
you know they're painting I mean they
why do chica look like that oh yeah but
it's a you can tell like this is like
stuff that they've done for like hours
and hours over and over like it's one of
those things really you mess it up okay
the next two minutes you're gonna have
to do all over again and I just like
it's very realistic too because he's not
always you know winning with ease like
you see him like Draghi and like on the
wall or something like that
yeah it's it's just really realistic and
I ditch I don't know it's pretty much
what I want for going back to what you
was saying for like a Batman film like I
hope in athletes like that where you
know he's like jumping off the walls
doing spin kicks you know he looks like
he knows hundreds of bunch of forms of
martial arts not just like you know one
style or you'd use a boxer like is that
or something that's the Bell and I've
always missed is the detective who's
also well trained mm-hmm like we
completely don't get the detective in
the know on verse like he you know he
shoots the bullet into the six different
walls but like that's not detection
that's having a lot of money like but
know him actually like investigating a
crime scene and actually gleaning some
information from it and being smarter
than the police would be interesting and
him actually being able to deflect fight
like it deflect blows using many
different martial arts that's that's
that is that man and yet somehow only
the games have gotten right so we were
we will never get that Batman because
for that type of movie people would have
to think um people don't like thinking
people complain when they have to think
Mother of God that Batman in the Justice
League because Batman will be able to
not be the focus of the movie and so
he'll be able to be like smarter than
everyone well I've always said forever I
just want them to make the Arkham games
into a movie that's all you have to do
and everyone will be happy yeah make it
a live-action movie yeah it's it's proof
in the success of the games like clearly
it's a successful game it would make a
successful movie yeah but back to their
double the fighting thing is great I
mean I love it it's a but I'd also like
to fighting in a Captain America Winter
Soldier I thought that the opening scene
with the stealth oh it's all like that
it's just fantastic so I have no
complains that too but I do agree with
you on the whole thing about him being
exhausted showing Rick a realistic human
person I mean I mean I'm not I wasn't
saying Captain America's fight sequences
are bad I just prefer the daredevil
style better because I can see what the
hell's going on it's like if you know
like at the beginning of Captain America
with him in the guy that's gonna be a
villain but they're like fighting oh no
yeah that's rock the leaper yeah yeah
the leaper that was it yeah and the two
of them fighting now that was that was a
good sequence to I I'm just not a fan of
fight sequences where it's so shaky that
you just don't know what's going on the
board it cooked right they could have
very easily have done that with
daredevil I mean what do you think about
the fight sequence if you ever said too
much light well in terms of fight
sequences and a technical standpoint if
you chop them up they're gonna look more
family-friendly so that's why they've
done that that one they show to seem
really adult they are holding everything
still so you see everything but there is
a lot I'm impressed by it because there
is a huge risk in doing that because if
you don't do that right um that was
actually a spin-off to Sailor Moon a
live-action version of Sailor Moon that
had fight scenes called pretty Guardian
Sailor Moon and they wanted you to see
everything in the fight scenes and it
was terrible because it wasn't well
choreographed so that it was a risk and
it seems to have worked perfectly well
like for me the fight scenes in
daredevil I think took their it took
elements from like John wick and it took
elements from old boy like the scene in
old boy
he's like fighting through the building
and it's literally that shot from
daredevil where he's fighting in the
hallway and like multiple times over
where it's just one gigantic cake of him
beating up a whole bunch of people now
in Oldboy he's breaking more bones and
you know and all kind of stuff me I'm
killing people and so on it's far more
gruesome but that's exactly what it felt
like and to me to see all that done in
one take is impressive yeah unbelievable
one take well yeah as far as we're
concerned it was one take it works you
know what if you know what you're doing
it doesn't matter like I'll take it I
would rather have a really sweet looking
one take shot than a like cut to crap
Barney and fight oh yeah yeah I agree
and and and this and III agree you know
I agree with Harrison you guys that the
the best element of the fight scenes was
that he was getting tired like the
course would be like like why is he just
easily crushing this guy like I should
be destroying this guy like it you know
and then just move on to the next guy
and it's it's not like that like he
throws three or two or three punches and
you see the fatigue kicking in ya see
he's just like oh my god like I'm really
getting tired of fighting these guys I
like I like it that sequence in the
second episode there okay I'm really
working that one because it's it's not
to spoiler be happy a lot of you
probably watch that one by now but my
favorite sequences in that is him in the
other guy both getting exhausted oh my
god they're both doing on that same note
I like that almost I don't know if it
was even an intentional Batman homage
but the new Batman stuff when he when
he's done with the fight and then he
goes to the void he's like stuff is also
heavy and I'm just oh my god pick you up
take you out of here yeah that was
amazing moving keeping with our
daredevil topic like that I mean another
thing that I notice about the daredevil
TV show which is actually a thing that
is actually I've had a few people get
into the Marvel shows based upon this
being the fact but every movie and
everything has not really focused too
much on their real lives I think Captain
America has gotten the closest to
focusing on hey he is a guy from the
1940s dealing with being in the current
you know world because even in agents of
shield they don't focus in their realize
it's always a Jillson top secret shield
stuff you know so I mean how do you feel
like I'd like air show you to open it in
faster you take this one second because
with three of us talked a lot already so
curious how do you guys feel about them
really focusing on Matt Murdock the
lawyer and foggy and Karen page and
they're not focusing in them as hey
they're just side characters to push
daredevil along but as it go he is a
lawyer if he's thinking kittens and fog
he's trying to do this and they can't
even afford the Wi-Fi um what do you
think about that I love it I mean I love
I actually like it more when you know
use your supporting characters because
it helps drive the story you know what I
mean there they're there to help tell
different angles of the story you don't
always
I mean clearly we're there to watch
Daredevils the daredevil show but who
the hell is supporting characters you
know it's it gets a little tiring and
you it helps actually helps his
character with you know and I don't it's
hard to spoil err but when characters
you know are worried about him if he's
missing or you know it just adds a lot
of another dynamic and elements in there
which is really cool so and then it
could even you know like little twist in
the end and stuff so I love when they
focus on supporting characters because
some supporting characters and some
movies I actually like more than the
main characters depending if they're
written well so I like foggy oh I don't
know if any of you guys notice that fog
is actually uh from Mighty Ducks yes I
really familiar I caught her fly her
down butterfly egg with Ashton Kutcher
there you go but he's also really like
like I like how they're making him you
know really likable and kind of kind of
goofy but still serious so I'm like in
the relationship he has with his little
lady at they they hired I mean what do
you think about a fast haven't having
the whole real world aspect to daredevil
being so prominent the show I mean I
absolutely love it I mean if anyone who
watches my stuff already knows this but
I I'm not the biggest fan of action I
like it being that yeah I think it has
its place in this John no definitely
because it's kind of lights based upon
but I love mundane stuff and I love the
drama like day to day get his coffee
talk about fax machines like
like the comic that I think had one of
the best stories last year and it got
cancelled and I'm still pissed off about
that with she-hulk cuz no one would read
it cuz they were like I don't think no
no shut up and read it
so with this focusing on the mundane and
the drama I loved it and every second of
it yeah hey Rob you watched all of it
you're the only one so I mean how do you
feel this I mean I've only seen the
depths of 6/10 up to this point we
really see the lawyer side do they just
go away and you're like I'll finally
think whatever yesterday only gonna be
you sent a little message over hey I got
only yeah ya know without without
spoiling it there's definitely a lot
more emphasis on the personal life of
daredevil and his co-stars foggy Nelson
and and and Karen age then then
everybody else and and that's that's
what I love I agree that's one of the
things that I really love about this
series is there so much emphasis on the
characters life and that and I think I
even I even mentioned that you know when
when I was talking about you know life
of kingpin or whatever it was
I mean II was conscious not like that is
all the other characters in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe we know Thor smash
gar but we don't know what his life was
like when he was being raised except for
that one scene in Thor where his father
was like and that's how we got this
giant icebox is because like we fought
frost giants and that's it like it
wasn't that cool I've only had time to
tell you that story you know in Captain
America the whole backstory of Captain
America as a kid is giving him given you
in the comics they counted America first
vengeance like there's no focus on them
as people outside of them fighting stuff
and that I think is really what made men
were not cool I think that's one of the
benefits of having a Netflix series is
you can spend so much time expanding on
the character more so than you can on
then you you know in a simple just film
even if it's a film based on one
character that's still just kind of the
way it the way it goes but yeah then
they do a lot of focusing on him and
especially I think foggy Nelson is I was
a great character like I think his role
in the series leading up to the end he
was a great sidekick for we're not
really sidekick but
great you know close friend for Matt
Murdock can I'll not leave you buddy
I'm really everyone's great everyone's
doing a great job foggy he's great the
relationship between you and Matt is
gut-wrenchingly good especially the
further down you go rosario Dawson does
a really nice job gotta give mad props
to her clearly there's a point in the
series where the money runs out and
rosario Dawson is alluded to as opposed
to appearing in the show the was the
other thing
I can't wait for Ben Urich to leave the
bulletin for the bugle in season two I'm
sure that where they haven't said that
right it's I mean like Ben Urich is by
the way that's another person we have
talked about Ben Urich is great the guy
plays him is terrific
nobody's from the spider-man supporting
cast yeah he is as much a spider-man
character as kingpin is so it's like
they're both very hand-in-hand
um and and Urich is a great character
the guy who plays him whose name escapes
me at the moment is really really good
I love the I actually really like the
the race swap for him I've read a bunch
of reviews of the show none of them have
mentioned them which means either
nobody cares or or Ben Urich is so
obscure that nobody knows either way
works for me love what they're doing
with him
let me Ben York is relatively obscure I
mean Ben Ben Urich vineyard became super
popular one because he knew Daredevils
identity in the comics and then chose
not to reveal it all right and then also
because he drew the bad attention of
kingpin Wayne did an expose in the
comics yeah and then he drew the bad
attention of Norman Osborn when he
didn't expose unknown Oswalt which is
the reason why
Osborn targets him during civil war
that's why you have to read the tie and
you don't need to read that you can just
make a pulse and you don't need the
woman who plays Vanessa is also fabulous
oh god she's so good and you get it like
you get his relationship with her
and it's nice that she's not in when
she's revealed or introduced she's not
relegated to like a plot device which is
what she is in the comics most most the
time yeah that's really cool everyone
like within the first few minutes of
meeting her you get it again you get the
relationship but you get what kind of
person she is and that's the case with
everyone I think the fact is like they
don't introduce a character extraneously
or for no reason like everyone supports
the story and and is also rich developed
character in their own right and so it
works really well like the show is just
it's just a it's just a it's just a well
produce a show like yeah very well I
think that last time that was on I think
podcast with you guys where guys are
asking about flash and arrow which I
love action flash actually owned it
probably like well now that this is out
but I wish that all these shows were
done in the same you know same
production value as daredevil you know
or like the game of Thrones and not
accomplish oh but and stuff like shows
that are high quality so like Game of
Thrones house of cards stuff like that
or it's just like this looks like a
movie yeah I mean this could be in the
theaters there's a TV show it looks like
a TV show run out but we're daredevil
and all these other you know like a show
it's you know it's the wire with
superheroes in it like it's amazing yeah
right here with the wire with
superheroes that's probably the best
analogy for not I mean it's as amazing
as the flash TV show is can you imagine
how much better would be with with the
production value of the daredevil series
yes make that costume so much better
awkward without material no one is going
to be the fastest man alive in that
material they're just gonna be super
shaped all right so here's my question
for air so so in the series so far were
you
with Vanessa with the girlfriend I guess
should I say I don't wanna spoil no we
can't we can't we'll give it away let's
let's let's wrap up the daredevil
discussion right now because we can't
talk too much further into it this week
because obviously I just came out of
Friday not even all of us have been able
to watch all of it only Rob so um I
think as we're at the halfway for what I
think it's a good time to bring up
convergence let's go ahead move over to
right expect topic we do have a whole
bunch of books here and I think we
should open this discussion with Eris
what was your favorite convergence pick
for the first week ha well the to stick
out to me it's either gonna be Superman
or Knightly an Oracle those are my two
favorites yes Superman felt to me like
it was very much like you know which was
supposed to be pre new 52 Superman you
know where I was like this feels like
old Superman which which is fine because
that's radiant like I was like I forgot
how much I liked Priene 52 pretty new 52
Superman you know I was like maybe I do
want this super I do find that funny
though because I agree 100% like I
actually really like the story arc said
the new Superman has been going through
but as soon as they picked it up and I
started reading convergence like all of
those old feelings of Superman deaths
but but and I'm like this is I love I
miss him he's so great but the only
thing that I remember is I never bought
the old Superman books like I loved him
as a supporting character in the
universe because he's just so goddamn
powerful you were like and he's so like
everything has to be discussed out I'm
super strong I will just end this
Superman book you see a captain Thunder
this Shazam from the flashpoint world so
in there there little fight was awesome
and you know I just the whole spoilers
everyone if the resident it's actually
on the cover thing that spoiler Lois
Lane is pregnant in it because
virgins yeah in the convergence world
like I think what most people know or
Superman's fans will know Superman
wasn't able to get her pregnant in there
because he's Kryptonian so the DNA
wouldn't match but now that they're deep
powered under this dome the convergence
world he was able to which I thought was
really awesome so it's cool to see like
and if in the second issue cuz he's
filming a two-part series if you know if
the baby's born or if they allude to it
being a super-powered baby which could
be cool
yes it's really open that this goes in
the direction that we're all thinking
like if Kerberos supermen cells well
we're going to have a pre new 52
Superman story or continuing yeah want
to see it back yes well the whole thing
more convergence it's like it's really
you know it's not done yet but it's
really weird cuz you know Dan DiDio is
saying you know continuity won't matter
anymore but we basically saying they're
just gonna tell stories and well to me
how I look at it is like because they're
saying that keeping their 25 new 52
books right but they're taking the new
52 off of it but those will be in
continuity because those are the
best-selling books so you know they're
keeping Batman Flash Justice League so
that'll be you know you're still endgame
will still be work with Batman all the
flash stuff will still go over don't the
other 24 bucks it's like oh well let's
just see what sells
I feel like the convergence is a testing
ground you know everyone's you know
they're really loving the Superman book
like you know you just said so they'll
give us pretty new pre new 52 Superman
or just picking [ __ ] it's like their way
to experiment so but I don't know that's
my theory I mean that could it could be
a little different so I'm really curious
to see how it's gonna go cuz we're only
what to issues and if you want to count
the zero issue convergence yeah so
tomorrow is the second one I guess or
third what worlds you know are gonna
live and whatnot because that base
basically all it's saying is whatever
world's lives that's the title you're
gonna get so very curious to see what
happens well yeah my favorite was
probably Superman and then just under
that is a Nightwing in Oracle which is
really comic big fit everyone has a big
Batman fan but I wrote a big also big
fan of Nightwing a Barbra corners
relationship and I kinda also a'dope
reminded me again if I think I still
like Barbara Gordon more in the
wheelchair I'm like this just adds a
really cool dynamic and she's you know
she's like the brains of the entire DC
Universe and that ending panel damaging
panel yes yes sound like Barbara Gordon
man that's friggin Gail Simone so yeah
oh and she was swinging for them no she
was out for blood in that issue
she's like no Barbara's back and I'm not
screwing around okay it's almost like no
one's watching like that really feels
like everyone who
wanted to go back I would have resisted
in new 52 was like house is going to
explode yeah it was like an Nightwing
Oracle book it felt more like but to
pray like gelus-- mines run them birds
of prey it really reminded me of that
and I don't know that that's one of my
favorite comics at all time yeah well in
the Oracle issue
I love the how like she you know you
hear our thoughts and a little like the
green bubbles she's like narrating the
whole thing and just in it you see like
her conflict and if there's this thing
with mr. freeze how people were coming
complacent with the world or you know
they just don't care anymore
so I just the whole her whole arc in
like what she was trying to convey it
was really cool like it was a really you
know emotional book where you're like
wow it made you think like what would
happen if you were really in a world
like that would you start becoming like
well nothing matters anymore why don't
you there's lightning too that we're
stuck in a fishbowl essentially so
what's the point but and then like loss
at the ending was just like oh yeah
we're back and we're back here's a
question I have about convergence just
really quick because I've read a couple
of the of the tie-ins but they're
calling the minis and this is one of the
few events ever where I'm like wow these
tie-ins are great where's Ben hocus
where they're horrible right where's pre
flashpoint Batman that's Batman and is
that Batman and son yeah well Batman and
Damian but this is actually my complaint
with the entire convergence event
they're basically like oh we have all
these different worlds we're different
eggs but they're not specifying who's
from what and the biggest confusion you
get out of that is the three Batman
books because which one of those is pre
flashpoint which one of those is pre new
52 you know because they're all like
they're all pre flashpoint because they
all bled into each other and that's like
saying that was like saying pre
flashpoint was a universe in and of
itself because the way that they tried
to make new 52 a more palatable for most
of us was that no it's not separate
universe everyone was folded into the
new 52 everyone was made into that like
it's the same Batman
from from pre flashpoint in new 52 but
it's not what my big question that was
every one of the Gotham City's is a
different Gotham City right we're from
rediff er n't bat-family and they're not
necessary universes as much as they're
from different time periods in the same
chronology like there's nightfall Batman
nightfall still happened pre fashionable
well no but like okay but here's here's
a really good question like Superman
number one since all the cities that
we've seen so far as part of the times
for convergence all take place in Gotham
we've got Superman number one all right
we've got Superman like would you know
Harkin alas what's going on here and the
flashpoint group is like it's curtains
for you old man
like where's Batman in that yeah well
this is happening like is Batman just
sitting in this cave watching it all go
down like I'll just wait and watch right
that's my book he's making his new suit
that the blue rabbits rabbit suit is
everyone calling it so I will say this
like like as someone bad because back
when you guys were reading this stuff
like what you guys are reading this
little bit was initially happening that
was my good but when I was reading
that's like when when all this stuff was
initially happening like you guys were
reading that I was off reading Marvel so
for me like a lot of this stuff is brand
new like like I'm looking at pre-crisis
or I guess what a pre flashpoint
Superman and for me like that's like wow
and and this is here's the funny thing I
finally understand what people are
talking about when they say pre
flashpoint Superman was better because
there is the stick point like there's
there's a single scene like the single
panel and Superman number one when he's
going against I guess the flashpoint
version of Shazam all right and he grabs
him and says like like I guess you are
less than nothing and like pounds them
into the ground
and it just looks epic as hell you know
what that book had me with that first
scene when he's patrolling Gotham as
nobody and the the flamethrower dude
douses him in flame and then Superman is
reborn from fire
and you're like yes you are like you're
back finally ditch the stupid battle
armor
you're not tortured and miserable you're
saying well I'm glad because like one
thing that I disliked about the Harley
Quinn book is that we spend an entire
book reestablishing who Harley Quinn
really is like anybody cares right
but the bet that Superman books spent
like the first two pages and the like
Superman is you know because I think
that the most vocal complaints have been
about DC's portrayal of Superman and so
they're like here also could also it
could also be Jergens his way of
answering that question cuz Jurgens is
like I don't know I've never actually
read any interviews with him talking
about the new 52 but like he clearly has
a fondness for the pre flashpoint
universe so that could just be story and
Steve had like you can you can just
think like the waste people I mean every
time you see Superman like once his
powers come back every time you see him
he's like Superman yeah by the way note
about that issue in particular I love
that they had Dan Jergens who has drawn
Superman for 20 years and and has drawn
some of the most iconic images of
Superman he writes it they got Lee weeks
to draw it to kind of combine this like
modern book with a quid like an
old-school if you can even say that like
Superman
creator to kind of I don't want to say
elevate it just kind of propels it to
this like like so that it holds up under
modern scrutiny I just feel like though
likely weeks's art like owns in that
book and manages to capture the essence
of Superman pre flashpoint while also
telling a story that you can with with
today's sensibilities with a flake with
with a modern eye for art I don't know I
just I really like that blend I was like
this is what this is what it should be
like that was kind of my opinion was
like this is beautiful like I mean going
through that it was a beautiful you done
comedy I mean yeah it was and like to me
that's that's what really got like
that's why when I when I read like well
I went through all those times I said
okay Superman one is right at the top of
my list of my favorite comics because it
was it was beautiful the way it was done
I mean you had the really cool action
sequences you had the relationship
between him and Lois Lane
where she was like what in the world is
going on and and then you have like the
emaciated Superman from the flashpoint
universe that shows up and he was like
you're coming with me because you're
Lois Lane and reasons and Lois Lane like
she's screams for Clark and Clark's just
like totally you know being set upon by
the flashpoint group like that that
right there I think was was really cool
because that's that's something that
I've never really gotten from from new
video to Superman I've never sat down in
read a new for you to super maybe
because he seems lifeless maybe it's
because he doesn't have the same history
as a free flash point Superman but I sit
down and I read this story about pre
flashpoint Superman and he looked like
he's drawn and he's written like a guy
that's seen some things like he's right
Superman looks like he looks like you
would expect like a teenage kid like I
just got all these superpowers and now
I'm just gonna go save the world I don't
care anything about it I can't relate to
him and doesn't matter to me but there's
just something about this pre flashpoint
Superman that's just like a lot about
the preview for Superman we also well I
think across the board we've all enjoyed
it
but I want to ask because you're a fan
of Flash I know a lot of us enjoy the
show I know foul states the costume how
do you guys feel about the Wally West
thing where another guy conveniently
happened to be in Gotham at the time of
the dome going down but this time with
his kids and he ends up Wally West I
mean basically runs around meets up with
the the captain current crew and they
end up fighting against an entire like
an evil version of everything today and
I'm like what is gonna happen to Wally I
know how do you guys feel about that one
why don't we haven't read that issue yet
though you gotta read that one was
pretty interesting that was it was it
was fast back from the zoo crew now
apparently it's fast back in Wally West
with his kids Jay and iris Virgil I know
how to pronounce the sons and I am John
iris going against the flashpoint Wonder
Woman and and I was I got to the end of
this comic and the first thing I thought
of was like a Tekken video game or like
Street Fighter and it's like Wally West
versus Wonder Woman
reading this I I mean like coming from
somebody that never really followed the
pre flashpoint DC I don't really see
what's so special about Wally West that
makes him so amazing like see I'm the
complete opposite I like grew up with
Wally West being the flash and I have a
really hard time giving two shits about
Barry Allen I don't get the Geoff Johns
love fest for Barry Allen I think the
whole problem is nostalgia geoff johns
in like our error you're the same kind
of boat as us eras where it's like Barry
Allen was our flash yeah well Wally West
is the next generation if I that's the
one they all grew up with we all grew up
on Barry Allen flash so we're all like
you can have like my favorite flash was
Bob Allen and remember when he like
absorb the Speed Force into himself and
he was the first one to do that was the
only fastest man alive don't you
remember that when he died cuz no one
liked him I like the same thing about
very yeah I mean I like Barry sacrifice
herself
Clark was beat to hell beat to hell by
the Rogues that's like because he had to
sacrifice himself to stop a bomb coming
on now excuses so you like like the
flash the flash isn't like another flash
the chat is the chat pretty much is
split like I mean your people in the
chat who are like Oh Barry Allen yeah
all day long and there are some people
who were like no Barry Allen such Wally
West is the best and it's it's funny to
me the matter like that divided I mean
you know in the end I think it'll be a
cool story but I just have a hard time
looking at it I mean I'm gonna I mean I
love this like I love the story element
like I like what's going on I like to do
gave us this really short Tour de France
of you know the whole you know battle
world and or not battle world of
well you know that it's profit what I'd
like to call the flash conundrum of
everyone being divided as to which flash
it's a favorite is Batman there's always
been Bruce Wayne we didn't have we
didn't have like Bruce Wayne in the 90s
and then in the entire 2000 Dick Grayson
yeah well no one can say that they liked
John Paul Valley more than they like
Bruce Wayne I know you didn't but they
seemed assuming we've always had Clark
Kent will have different versions of
Clark Kent but it's always been Clark
right but with the flash it seems like
we gonna knew what every six years or so
there's the main flash you know I mean
it is what we had Barry then we went to
Wally then we would depart then we went
back to Barry and went to Wally yeah so
what you're saying is iris west 2020
here's the thing is Jeff John still yeah
is still uh pretty much in charge
everything over DC was chief creative
officer then you're not getting Wally
West because of that that Wally West is
now once again a kid like they just like
oh we're completely reinventing him he's
uh he's biracial and he's a kid again
it's awesome is sors gonna make it sober
for no reason I think a big reason for
Wally West is because of the Justice
League cartoon which is also you know so
everyone you know he's funny
which I love while he's my second
favorite flash so I'm not trying to
knock him it's just my favorite story
because that's what I grew up with but
now I know and that's the exact same
reason why a lot of people like for us
Hal Jordans the better Green Lantern but
I know a lot of people that are like why
is the Green Lantern white like what
about that was the thing that like just
as a quick aside Jon Stewart is a missed
opportunity for DC across the board you
could have built like you have an entire
generation of new DC fans were brought
in from the cartoon who's whose whose
version of green lantern is John Stewart
and with you're looking for like because
clearly when they created the new 52
when they created their their roster of
justice leaguers they they you know what
I was gonna say promoted cyborg who I
don't think anyone is really a big
The Promise cyborg is the poor guy is
like cybers now on the Justice League
hey watch the cameras yeah we're gonna
go fight the best for the Transformers
he couldn't guard the base people know
me for loving the Titans I'm a huge
Titans band like that's what I'm known
for
even in the Titans I don't care about
cyborg the tower
nobody cares about cyborg like I don't
even but like in that like I know fast
gonna freak out but I really liked that
only Teen Titans cartoon the the fake
anime one I I didn't mind that I didn't
mind it yeah but I really liked that
cyborg that's like one of the few
cyborgs I actually was like okay I get
him now but my point being like to get
rid of Hal because John is already a
Green Lantern you just have Hal do other
things as clearly he's want to do based
on your Sinestro Wars and your Red
Lanterns and all your boys e-bill
communities know what blew my mind is
what during the whole entire Geoff Johns
Hal Jordan run house Orton was off later
tipping all this other crap left the
Justice League and instead of just
giving us Jon Stewart or even Guy
Gardner as the earth green laser they're
gonna make Simon Baz and the forgetting
exists like having a cool tattoo that
glows though I did my entire Green
Lantern run and I get I keep any
questions now like will you do the
origin assignment bad like honestly
probably not because he just seems to
have disappeared
nobody is anymore no one save America
last I Redax I haven't kept up with with
his stuff or seen him in anything but
last I remember what he was in Justice
League United or America where Green
Arrow is trying to like have them team
up and he's like yeah I'm busy doing
Green Lantern things so quick question
what did you guys think of conversions
Titans that was actually my next issue
we were gonna talk about um
me I actually like to Titans because it
picked up where we left off with Arsenal
and like everything I felt a little
weirded out with Arsenal having kids and
like I've given up my artisans storage
that was my favorite as she listened it
was my favorite I don't know like I
thought it was gonna be like the Teen
Titans no that's another book which is
also see what I can't even acknowledge
is that they stay open by being like
yeah these are the guys you know not
about them yet I mean it focuses on
Starfire focuses on Arsenal and it
focuses on whatever that last chick's
name is the third one I can write
focuses on her you haven't read much DC
I told you like okay
thousands since since you're relatively
new here here's the deal
I swear that's a Marvel guy like Marvel
is my bread and butter that's where I
make my bones
alright DC is all relatively new I
started DC a new 52 to be honest she's
she's in the Titans x-men crossover I
didn't read that
what would I read it but every to change
how you like some I know it is so Wonder
Woman know this is the greatest
intercompany crossover Hult hi you're so
full of hoo-hah it's like it's like
saying Rob you should read like the
Avengers an ultra force crossover
because you know what you're saying you
should read The Avengers jail a
crossover ultra force they might come
back well Donna Troy wasn't just a
member of the Titans she was at one
point Wonder Woman's clone and then she
was her sister and then she was Madonna
Tori has officially been brought back
and she is the clone and she's trying to
take over as the queen of the Amazons
she is she has been brought back into
and the Finch run for a run cast because
it's really
I am I the only person in it like Brian
Azzarello was a great run the finches
run is not as good but it's not bad I'm
enjoying it
people like Tony s Daniels Deathstroke
where it looks fantastic but that's it
by the way just a quick plug for the
weekly pulled net if you go there you'll
be able to read our coverage of Titans
number one written by Jason Evans so I
like about Titans number one blah blah
so what I liked about Titans number one
because I didn't actually get anything
because I was too shocked by yes I loved
it because it focused on the characters
emotions and their interactions with one
another and then it had action elements
towards the end at least four-fifths of
this book was all about emotions and
setting up their mental state which is
what the Titans is about it's a drama
with action elements and these
characters just happened to be in the
superhero world and that was the point
of the Titans and the new 52 totally
missed that and like both Teen Titans
runs is who doesn't get the pulling of
the birth relaunches but the latest one
is all about like social media so I
loved that I loved the Titans and with
Marv Wolfman on the New Teen Titans book
it's probably gonna be similar with it
focusing on the drama and the emotional
states question well I think I think
with the Titans book it was interesting
to look at Arsenal from a non superhero
just trying to live a day-to-day life
perspective like like all that's gone
now like I'm just kind of a guy that's
just trying to do the right thing and
make sure like these kids and this
orphanage that I've opened up or taking
care of and that's kind of a cool thing
I think but I think that when it comes
to stories that I think it's more
important to focus on the characters the
drive of the characters the basis behind
the characters then to just jump in and
say oh my god now we're fighting and
then you're like this is or this is the
craziest biggest baddest thing that'll
ever happen ever like in the history of
anything that's ever happened this is
the craziest ever like it's just you
know like I don't I don't really dig
that too much I like good character
development and I think that with Orson
looking at his character from just a
personal perspective and then at the end
at the end of the story is like okay
look I guess I've got to go back to
being Arsenal again any bus not for me
butts not a zero but sawdust gear so
it's okay let's just go try to rescue
you know Starfire and Donna Troy from
the extremists let's rescue them okay
well let's let's move on to the three
books that no one that is on nobody's
topless Nick Adam question and the
Justice League book right yeah I mean I
don't even really read those yeah I was
like confusing in the question I didn't
read either so it's cool but I read the
only one you did I was excited for it to
be Renee Montoya will there ever be a
day where Renee Montoya Smith those is
no longer links to bat woman no because
I like the idea of the like she's a
lesbian in comics great she doesn't
always need to be linked to the other
lesbian incoming to be married yeah
that's why like they were actually
really closely linked that's why yeah
they were really closely linked but life
goes on character Faust we have to
create another gay character it's really
hard to do that look I know that allows
you only get like five prominent gay
characters yeah warning for we do okay
so well alright fine okay she can take
Catwoman okay because she's bought I
know people in the real world but in
comics we can have more look I'm
executive of DC I'm telling you this is
this is how it would go like would you
calm down they gave you the the earth
two green lantern that no one's ever
heard I four years ago take that be
happy joy the star and then look I will
not rest until we heard drag queen
superhero
I really doubt that's gonna happen
really like I really want to see that
happen I want to see a story alright
here I want this story to open up like
to Wong foo
Oh is he like like this character like
getting like getting dressed putting on
a nylon stockings or like putting on
their lipstick like they're just a panel
we're like they're putting on lipstick
you know and like you see like like a
wig being put onto a head and then like
the next page is like a full body panel
and they're just like standing in style
yeah like I really actually just did a
comic of Deadpool drag queen as Jean
Grey what's gonna go in the channel next
week hold on Deadpool drag queen doesn't
hit me up on five funny side note the
video goes up next week I found a comic
where Wolverine couldn't fight an enemy
so he needed Deadpool to distract him
and the enemy was looking for Jean Grey
it was a robot so he got dead pulled the
drag queen is Jean Grey five dead fools
like what do you think empowers me is it
my bazongas but side note on that I
forgot to warn you era since you come on
like once a month pretty much ever since
we brought fast on conversations get
weird at times just not my fault someone
else that starts it every time it's
named after me but I've never started
you're the new guide has to go somewhere
could be the heiress if he can be though
hi so anyway yeah I mean so overall with
the question I mean I did read the atom
personally I felt like the atom was
pointless and I think that they just did
that as a shoehorn because the atoms an
arrow he's gonna have a comic for more
dollars well there wasn't reason enough
for me to buy it I mean it's like Adam
hasn't been developed in enough enough
an arrow for me to say oh my god I want
to run out and buy a atom comic I mean
it's not no probably was just a test bed
kind of thing that's just two issues of
the atom no one's gonna ask for more if
they do we can make no simple as that
yeah and the Justice League comic just
for me was like like this is probably
one of the worst time periods of the
Justice League why are we bringing back
all the c-listers on a comic I don't
care boys at fire and ice and blood wind
though it's like that brand of the of
the team oh no one you're honest
yay this is out I mean overall so
well it's gonna ask Eris cuz recover
kinda come come to where we gonna so
rant winding down how do you feel about
convergence after the first week we've
all made our videos of our opinions what
is your opinions um I don't have a final
opinion thus far I mean as of now I'm
just still kind of curious because I
haven't really done much I mean we're
only one at you tomorrow we'll get issue
two but uh it's it seems like we said
earlier like it's just everything's
either taking place within Gotham and
having the flashpoint world it seems
like so it's like that's the only two
things are really focusing on I'm I mean
I think it could be really cool as of
now I'm kind of liking I like the idea
that you know it's kind of like a battle
royale like a Hunger Games of comic
books
I like the idea I'm just curious to see
where they're gonna take it because it's
way too early to tell so what this is
gonna mean for the future VC is well I'm
more worried about you know I mean I
guess you know I'm still gonna have you
know my Batman book look about stayin
but I'm very curious to see as far as
hold the continuity thing like where
that's gonna go and what does that mean
as like are they gonna just leave it
because even some of the books they
launched that our official they're only
getting some of them only getting like
eight issues after that so it's like
okay so does that mean you're just gonna
do like limited runs for certain titles
and always keep interchanging to make
everyone happy some people some people
could jump out you know so it's like oh
yeah this is only gonna be the issues
it's gonna be you know a graphic novel
so you can just jump on that so I'm
curious to see there is this is
basically a story that's written around
a new business model is what it is what
it seems so I'm what I've been telling
everyone that follows me is you just
need to remember nothing is permanent in
comics this'll look like five years
maximum and annuity yeah well that's no
yeah it's everyone's always like what
someone does the comic books going back
side like what do you think I'll think
we'll be back in a year okay you know
what a great example for that real quick
I don't really go too much into it cuz
it is spoilers and probably some people
haven't read it yet but the death of
Deadpool they hyped that up in the last
six months and he literally ended and uh
it wasn't actually it was a great ending
for him but it wasn't spectacular and it
perfectly leaves the door open for him
to come back like there was no closure
to not like when Wolverine died were
there like okay we injured him he can't
heal
adamantium shell we're through the
gauntlet we are not letting him come
back it does because the Deadpool have
you guys read the Deadpool is everybody
read it I know what happens I didn't
read it I don't yeah no dollars okay
yeah the does so the death of Deadpool
ends with the earth-616 Ultimate
Universe incursion like that's what kid
that's what kills Deadpool but the
genius about that ending is that's what
kills everybody else too so if everybody
else if anybody else can come back but
that means Deadpool can come back so
like that's that's that's it's not like
a unique death I mean like you guys are
saying it's not like it was with
Wolverine where he's just encasing out
of man to him and he's just kind of
stuck and he's just dead and that's it
his healing factor is gone presumably he
just dies really fast or something like
that inside this case I'm out of mantium
whatever he said well he died the same
way as everybody else
so if Reed Richards from 6-1-6 comes
back in this new battle world and it's
just this you know reality portion of
six one six and X to the ultimate
universe and Reed Richards is standing
there
that means Deadpool can come back in the
exact same vein they can assign 'never
the whole thing and it's not a spoiler
is once Deadpool like the story's really
good it does close out the run there's a
few loose ends but the funny thing about
it is as he realizes the incursians
happening he's like wait the incursian
thing was real I thought that was just
my bedroom no one figured this out I
will say this before we eat before we
kind of finish up and wrap everything up
in the death of Deadpool when he was on
the farm and he sent those corpses to to
flag Smasher ultimatum and it was core
in a stores location was and they showed
up that following action sequences was
like one of the most spectacular
displays and ass-kicking that I've ever
seen in the testicles run like he
literally laid waste to an entire army
of people single-handedly isn't much of
a spoiler really I mean is what happens
but the whole thing is basically just
Deadpool just killing an entire army
yeah and he even says I'm going out with
a spectacular fashion yeah and the whole
point of it is basically because if
you've been reading the run
Deadpool is no basically deciding like
how does he handle the
family the daughter the friends having a
real life as opposed to being the Merc
with the mouth and he his decision is he
will kill Deadpool so he can be wait
Wilson that's the whole point of the
book yeah so he can move on and be and
then of course the incursion happens so
we're gonna get back congratulations
Deadpool you got a life finally oh you
can never escape it but it was
personally BL reason a man doing that is
because they're gonna bring back Merc
with the mouth Deadpool and not sad
clown Deadpool you're gonna get like
old-school jokey nothing makes any
goddamn sense ok guys so we're up to our
time let me hear that we typically have
I think we've done a great discussion
with converges we've done a great
discussion with daredevil here and I
want to appreciate I want to say thank
you to everyone who has joined us today
I think it's time for us to do our
closing remarks for everybody here and
what we're all coming through the rest
of the I can talk so we're doing that
week this week we just released a new
show which we call comic line where we
it's like everyone at the table read the
same book one story arc and then we just
kind of get into some of the themes and
ideas this week we did rage of Ultron
talked about like the humanity of Hank
Pym and Ultron and really just dug into
that graphic novel talked for about an
hour it's really fun show I don't know
it's gonna come back we'll see it's kind
of popular so maybe and you know back
issues gonna have daredevil in it I see
I actually like to copy glad I watched
it but I love the confusion by some of
your fan base and I love accomplice so
this is back issues with suits the idea
with baggage is as I read the book I
grew up in it and then I explain it to
people who don't normally read comics
and this one everyone read the story and
we all just get into it we don't
actually I'll go over the story we go
over the themes and concepts that are
that are raised the comments all seem to
notice that you all were jacket we did a
little bit we want to bring the jackets
in that's something that I've yeah I'm
working on that comics explained its
self robbed so tomorrow were probably
gonna release video about about the
infinity gems because for some
I don't understand why you guys love
cosmic level stuff [ __ ] lock this video
is like a hundred thousand views and
like like all that like The Living
Tribunal eternity because they don't
understand what's going on I guess
Boober cosmic I've noticed the eros
never does cosmic level stuff is it just
too much you just don't care I've done
I've done a few well I've got a few I
did dark side versus a way to dark side
understand us though the brief origins
in my versus up so I did that I mean
it's I love dark sides one of my
favorite DC villains so it's only a
matter of time before I do a history of
dark side episode which I'll get into
all that so with regards to you reply
yesterday that tweet then I said I was
like dorks night versus Galactus you
know that story right oh yeah I just
wanted to jump in so I'm like yes let's
do this let's jump in any debate that's
going on on Twitter the funny is you
won't even tank him and just if he sees
it's interesting he's in he's there he's
doing yeah I was just like Darkseid all
day long just to be like I don't know
whatever and then he was like uh well
Galactus eath world and I'm like let's
do this too because the way the story
ends like like Galactus is like there's
like all this like crazy chaos and
everything and Galactus is like it is
done my machine is finished and like
he's like there's nothing here and darks
lies like there's no life energy here
dude leaving but but no I thought that
that was kind of funny but after that'll
probably be the death of Deadpool and
then and then we gotta get like we got
to get prepped like we got to start on
getting ready for time runs out at the
end of the month so we got a yeah we got
a bunch of stuff we need to do to build
up for that so what is effective on it's
super effective have a seat have a way
to go to you I've been think about ever
the last 10 minute does it make a joke
about that
we're like prepare you didn't listen to
a word
Rob said that you're like I got this I
got this
I heard her Rob said something about
doing videos but so I'm doing something
completely new and doing a Teen Titans
based video my god I've never done that
and then I thought my twist things up
even more and do a Young Avengers video
and I'm just recapping convergence well
and what and what variation of our
variants is happening at variant comics
ha ha ha
also I heard the viewers who aren't
aware I don't know who would be unaware
of varying comics but if you want to
fill them in on the overall theme of
your channel cuz you're our guest today
so it's 4,000 justyou're every week now
houses the guy in the couch if I was
just like showed up one day and then
just never left on as a guest it just
kept coming back please all right my
channel is a variant so basically I talk
about all things comics or I do uh one
of the videos that's popular the most is
a history of is where I break down take
like you know 50 years of a character
and break it down like in ten minutes so
basically talk about all things comics
to do reviews of all the animated movies
of all the you know TV shows like
daredevil arrow basically any all things
comics if it's like comic book related I
talk about it but yeah this month we're
doing Marvel month which we started for
all of april's so we even got like a new
bumper for it and everything for the
whole month of April just celebrated
leading up to Avengers so like this
month we've already done we kicked it
off of the history Avengers we did a
history of vision this tomorrow's
episode is actually gonna be talking
about a Hulk vs. Hulkbuster Iron Man
which is really cool I know they fought
in the comics I was like this person won
but it's just cool to talk about so I'll
dive into that a little bit we're gonna
round out the month with some Scarlet
Witch Quicksilver and Ultron talk and
then some one shots here in there this
week's one shot will probably be a
something about spider-gwen
because everyone like spider-gwen so
that's that's what we're doing and then
going into May will probably I don't
toying around probably doing something
for convergence for a few weeks
celebrating that is that's gonna end at
May then going into June we got all the
new issues so that's the it's pretty
much the layout for variant fun for the
guys who were in the in lashing don't
forget to check the description where
you'll find a link to Erica's channel so
yeah all right you know my channel we're
just doing I don't even know we were
talking about I think we're doing about
in a Superman video we're doing a
Scarlet Witch video you get doing on it
okay and I was like that's it I'm done I
forgot I forgot to mention I'm doing
Game of Thrones recaps as well embracing
em I'm great embracing what people know
me as the off-brand comic book girl 19
bracing it you gotta change your hair
color but yeah no I'm the off-brand so I
can't have pink
it's got Rachel Bulger coming out on
Friday we got Batman Superman next week
we have Grayson's coming out Wednesday
you don't know who I am at this point go
over there oh look we've got like a list
of like 20 videos all scripted and ready
to go and it's like what comes out next
like they're all skirts they're ready to
go and don't it then something happens
like hey Deadpool just got a big big
bump now I gotta go write a Deadpool
script you have 20 squid scripts ready
to go ya know what I do is like what I
basically do is I have a crap ton of
backlog scripts like Grayson's been like
done for like a mantra putting it out on
Wednesday finally and what we do is if
it's a hot topic like The Avengers
movies or Deadpool we do one of those
videos and then if we don't have a hot
topic I just pull it off the list of
things we have backlog that's really
smart
like like I just now started getting
organized with all my videos like a
couple weeks ahead of time
well like the case of point range of
motion range of motion wasn't planned
everyone asked for it so that's our
Friday so I've wrote that one up and
then we pulled Grayson off the pile just
hey everyone else great so let's do that
so okay well I mean yeah thank you for
joining us as usual Eris I know you were
never discussing or to try to kind of
get you on pseudo regular but you're you
probably have the busiest schedule out
of all of us so yes
what are you amazing things so many no
it's fun yeah I like to be on whenever I
can it's a good time and I think outside
of that the week the pool would be back
next Tuesday just so that everyone's
working we are trying to get like an
official person that uploads the podcast
properly and he's being pain in the butt
but we're getting it done Ruby on iTunes
will be on soundcloud it should be up
today but knowing him it'll be up by
Saturday and we are also still trying to
move to a livestream platform so that
you'll have an actual weekly poll like
livestream channel where you can check
us out on our normal times our off times
and the podcast will happen there and
there would be some additional
discussions like Benny and Rob talking
about stupid crap or Salim Denny arguing
about why spider-man 2 is the greatest
film ever or you know that kind of thing
but also don't forget we do have the
weekly pulled net that is our website
where all of the weekly pool happenings
kind of converge into a secret war ok
wait really quick just that that that
monologue from tell us where he's like
some of you were part of an infinite
crisis well I thought was really cool
it's like there there's a failed
experiment and injustice yeah in this
first issue like ah I get it
I see what you know from the record I
was a little pissed off that injustice
was regulated to two pages and like and
they're done combat game it's probably
one of the best-selling Elseworlds
but you have to say that hand was just
really cool shot it was really cool
here's a problem like like we just been
they like they jump to earth to they
were just kind of like well like earth
to now
another converging with another episode
all right guys next week we'll probably
talk about convergence or whatever else
comes up so uh I think we got a comment
that I'm the king of the bad jokes okay
make sure you check out our community
check out all of our channels we
appreciate all of your time and as usual
we will see you next week right here at
the weekly poll episode turn it off